i can't find a love because my dad left
when i was one i can't find love because
my mum preferred my brother i can't be a
success because i never went to
university i can't speak in public
because i blush
without understanding when you describe
why you can't you keep it going if you
keep talking about the symptom your mind
keeps it alive because whatever you
focus on you get more of and so a lot of
people have language that's completely
irrelevant like yes i know your dad left
when you was one i know your mother
put you up into foster care and didn't
love you but that's that's then this is
now
and so they have outdated stories
outdated language they i can't do that
because uh
the classic when i held him oh my god my
boyfriend just ripped out my heart
stamped all over it killed me
and if i find love again it will kill me
i'm like darling he got bored and you
would have got bored too if you'd stuck
around and that was your starter
relationship go and find a better one
with someone amazing everything he loved
in you
you didn't take it home with him it's
still there so don't use that irrelevant
i found love and it killed me when it
ended so i found love the wrong person
i'm going to find it again with a right
person it's going to be amazing and
compelling he's going to fall in love
with my soul can you be together forever
because you've got to turn your mind on
and it loves exciting words dramatic
words
really loves words that make a pictures
if i said
to you
you can be the most phenomenal powerful
awesome incredible speaker when you
speak on stage everyone stops so listen
you could hear a pin drop they look at
you they hear what you're saying they
like you the thing is the client comes
in with a list like what i call a
shopping list i i i need to stop
drinking i need to get out of bed i need
to stop shouting at my kids i need to
take care of myself
and they like to go through the list it
takes a long time i go oh forget the
list let's look at what what i call what
lies beneath you know your problem
i don't think you're enough
where does that is ever
and a baby who's ever been born because
i shouldn't cry because i don't deserve
attention here i shouldn't throw up on
this white top my mom just bleached
no baby is ever born believing they're
not enough and so
again we look at where does this come
from this belief you're not enough who
told you that
where did you get that and when they go
oh yes it came from here
it's a game changer because they start
to tell
i'm enough people say but if i'm enough
don't i just lie on the couch and eat
potato chips all day no
when you know you're enough then you go
right i need a better relationship
there's a better career than this a
better better health than this here's
some things i wanted to start doing
today right now that will build your
self-esteem super fast the number one
thing
is to praise yourself there is nothing
nothing
nothing
that will build your self-esteem like
praise but your praises if you have
a shoppers and so you look really great
in the outfit yeah it suits you you must
buy it they have an agenda if your boss
says you're amazing at your job but i
need to give you work to do over the
weekend they have an agenda
someone dating you might have an agenda
and your mind knows everyone when you
say
i'm great at my job i'm smart i'm kind
i'm nice people like me there is no
agenda unfortunately when you go i'm
rubbish at my job i'm boring i always
mess up and i have no friends
your mind lets that into because your
mind doesn't really care if what you say
is right or wrong
good or bad healthy or unhealthy let me
prove that to you
i want you to put your hand in front of
your face like that i want you to close
your eyes i want you to imagine
you have a big fat juicy lemon and i
want you to
breathe in that wonderful lemon smell
and just squeeze it a bit and feel that
wonderful lemon texture because nothing
quite smells like a lemon so still
really believing you have half a lemon
in your hand
open your mouth
shove that lemon in there cram that half
a lemon into your mouth and start
chewing
and sucking and biting and swallowing
the flesh keep sucking all that lemon
flesh into your mouth bite it chew it
suck out the juice
and you will notice that what is
happening is
your body is responding to a thought as
if it's a fact
your body is responding to the image and
thought of eating a lemon as if you are
actually eating a lemon and it's making
a saliva because thoughts are things
and every thought you have
has a physical reaction in your body and
an emotional response to when you think
i don't have friends i can't talk to
people i can't take things back to a
store
i can't ask for special treatment
i don't know how to talk to people then
your mind accepts that as a fact just
like the lemon but when you say
oh i can talk to anyone i'm an
interesting person i'm warm and friendly
people like me and i can make eye
contact i'm good at my job i can ask
someone out on a date i can tell the
person i'm involved with what i need
your mind accepts that too and someone
recently said they keep a lemon on their
desk now and look at it every day i'm
sure they change it every month because
that lemon reminds them every day that
they are responsible for what they think
and feeling you know responsibility that
word means an ability to respond
so i want you to start to praise
yourself i want you to wake up in the
morning the first thing you go is i like
myself in powerful language you can
never say you can fall you're going to
mess that up you're going to ruin
everything
that's just not going to work out you
have to say the opposite okay
i've only got 10 minutes to prepare my
speech i only need 10 minutes i've only
got 10 minutes to get there that's
exactly how much time i need and if i'm
late i wasn't supposed to be there on
time i have a belief now when i get to a
party late it's because it wasn't i
wasn't meant to get there early i no
longer go my god i'm so late this is
going to be terrible if i i was recently
going in a cab across town to get a
train to work with a football team
and we got stuck in traffic and so i was
playing a game i thought oh my god i'm
going to miss the train this is terrible
i'm going to ruin my reputation the team
are going to be so upset
and i felt really sick and then i
started to say the trains run every 20
minutes it doesn't matter what's 20
minutes my material is so great they
have lots of time after all they
finished
practicing at three o'clock and and it
was fine
so all the way there i was playing a
game
and i actually got the train on time but
they really wouldn't have minded but i
could have ruined my day
made myself panicky and sweaty by going
oh my god i haven't got enough time and
now it's all ruined
and it's never ruined you can come back
from anything
and then i worked with a client who had
cancer and had to go into this mri
scanner and every time i saw him he said
i can't i can't do it i can't get in
that scanner and i said well i feel like
i'm in my coffin i feel like it's a
premonition of my death and i get in the
scanner i think well i've got cancer
and i'm gonna die and i said well i
freak out i press the button i have to
come out and keep saying look you've got
to go i can't i can't even be in there
for two seconds which is not true
whatever can i can't do it for even a
second he probably was in there for a
few minutes i said look
the words you say to yourself in that
scanner this is a premonition of my
death
i feel like i'm in a coffin
i feel like i'm suffocating and i can't
do it
that's a blueprint and your mind doesn't
like those words so how about these
words how about saying i'm in my bed at
home
and i'm just so chilled and i could lie
here for hours i'm chilled i'm relaxed
i'm blissed out you must
use words that make a picture you can't
go oh i'm okay really i'm quite good i'm
not bad this is okay
because when i say the words okay not
bad where's the picture
there's no pictures what i call fluff
when you say i'm chilled i'm blissed out
i'm ecstatic
i'm just lying here and i could do this
for hours it's just so cool
the mind goes you're right and when you
go i'm in a coffin and i'm suffocating
the mind goes you're right
see here's a great thing
you can choose any word you like you can
go well we're all going to be negative
and this half's going to be positive
that's your choice you know what you
can't choose
what you do to yourself when you say i'm
an idiot i'm a [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ] i've
got rocks for brains everything goes
wrong who would ever like me i've got
cellulite i'm a single parent i've got
no chance blah blah blah i didn't go to
college so i couldn't possibly do what
you do i got kicked out of college by
the way so you can definitely do what i
do and it was the best thing that ever
happened to me i can look at my life and
say being fired being dumped and being
kicked out of college
thank you god for putting that in
up to me because it changed my life it
was the best thing rejection
has been one of the best things that
ever happened to me being the least
favorite kid if i could have my life
again i'd go back and be the least
favorite kid because i thought i'm going
to show my parents that i'm something
and if i was the favorite i wouldn't
have done that i would have had a
totally different life if praise is
unfamiliar but criticism is familiar
when you say to someone like robin
williams oh my god that last show was
funny goes didn't you notice
i i've left out the visit i fluffed a
word it wasn't as good as the one before
so if you're not used to praise you'll
reject it and if you're used to
criticism you'll add it in
because we do what's familiar so if we
say to someone i love your book they go
oh actually it's not that good
the other one is much i love your talk
oh i got it in a car boot sale it's five
years i've got a hole in it so if we
haven't got praise we actually reject it
and you just have to say to yourself i'm
going to make this familiar i'm going to
praise myself for every day might feel
weird but i'll keep doing it it's a bit
like running you know running isn't
familiar especially around beverly hills
but if you put your shoes on and go for
a run on concrete eventually it becomes
familiar and then you like it i mean
sticking a lens in your eye that's the
weirdest thing very unfamiliar the first
few times oh my god i'm coming in my eye
like that and then after a while you can
do it almost without thinking because
you get used to it you can make anything
familiar or unfamiliar we used to live
in ward cities and and our strength came
from numbers we we were in a group and
with numbers we survived now you can
live in an apartment
you can have cats and dogs you can have
your grocery drive you can never see
anyone and you could live until you're
110
but we still feel this feeling i'll die
if you reject me no you won't you'll get
stronger
but you know for women especially if you
went back 500 years ago you're a
hunter-gatherer and your guy died out
spearing a wildly beast you would die
who's going to raise your children who's
going to feed you
so in our evolutionary psychology we
have this fear i'll die if you don't
like me
and we try to get over it by buying
stuff and going to the gym
and having our hair down or getting a
nicer car
or trying to impress people and what you
should do is impress upon your mind look
i know you think i'm going to die from
rejection i'm not
actually it's going to make me stronger
and if you can dialogue with yourself
and go
okay just been dumped i feel a bit sad
it's not going to kill me it's that was
a starter relationship the next one is
going to be way better
then it does make you stronger people
think the brain is really complicated
it's not it's actually quite simple you
need to know three things about your
brain to always get what you want and
the first thing is your brain does
exactly
what it thinks you want it to do because
it listens to everything you say so when
you say things like oh god you know i
got dumped it's so painful i never want
to go through that again all your mind
can pick up is you you don't want to be
in a relationship again when people have
a miscount and go i could never never go
through that again i'd rather die than
go through that again
your mind is speaking up oh right well
that's that's a statement that's
actually a command to me to make sure
you never go through miscarriage again
and that that's how you get unexplained
infertility
which is something else i've been
working on a lot recently
because the mind listens to what you see
people go oh i went on this fly i
thought i was going to die and do it
again i'll never get them to play if
this plane lands i will never ever get
on a plane again and of course it lands
like oh it's just turbulence the next
time they go to the airport of a massive
panic attack because your mind's like
hang on a minute you said i never want
to fly again
and so if you haven't got what you want
it's because you're giving your mind
very confusing messages your mind's
number one job is to listen to what you
say to interact on it the second job is
to move you towards pleasure and away
from pain and it will always always
always do more to avoid pain so let's
imagine you've gone for an interview
you've done a public speech thing like
me and you've stood up you've gone uh
and you said oh my god i'm never doing
this again and you'd have a terrible
presentation and one of my clients who
worked for sony was saying that she had
to stand up and just say to sony this is
a new band from camden and she stood up
and went this is a new band from
and they're called
uh
i couldn't do it i just was the simplest
thing and my boss had to take over and
that i was explaining to her that when
you do that and go oh my god i don't i
don't want to do it i don't want to do
this again your mind is now going to
make sure you don't do it again so the
next time you go to speak it will give
you a panic attack or make you ill and
if you say to yourself oh my god i'd
love a week off in bed or i'm dreading
next wednesday your mind is so in tune
with you your week off in bed you wake
up with a flu and your mind's like there
you go how cool am i there's your week
in bed you don't want to go to that
speech i've woken you up with diarrhea
so now you can't go
that's what the mind does when i was
giving my first ever presentation about
my first ever book i woke up with the
most excruciating mic i've ever had one
before i thought wow
i must have been saying to myself so i
don't want to do this
because i've got this migraine and i
actually went and did it and i didn't
have the migraine until i stepped back
off the stage again
and i realized that i was communicating
very badly with myself so you must never
say nervous say excited because your
mind listens so those three things are
your mind does what it really thinks you
want to do if you're very very specific
and so i want this and this i want to be
a great speaker i want to deliver things
i want to be fantastic at sales i want
to be able to look people online sell
them things and come across as really
authentic
your mind will understand
and if you make those pictures really
good
and pleasant you'll move towards them to
change your life in the next 30 days for
free click the link right below me and
if you want my tony robbins affirmations
for success video click the link right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe i'll see you there